before i run out of time with you i
actually want to do a follow-up on the
boys if you don't mind um i noticed the
facial hair is in full effect
uh does this mean that you're going back
to start filming a certain new season
soon yeah we're starting uh i think
august the 22nd we're gonna be starting
uh season four so i'm
you know getting back getting my butcher
back on and uh i can't wait you know
it's uh
uh it's uh it's it's a fun game to play
with you know we um
uh we we work hard and play hard and and
uh i can't i can't wait to see where
they take the characters um from where
we leave them at the end of the season
yeah i've seen the whole season three
and uh i might i cannot wait for the
next season does eric tell you in
advance like how early does eric or
anyone involved in the production
actually tell you about what's coming in
the next season
well what are we now we're about two
months away from filming and i have no
idea so
that'll tell you something uh but
they're not too far away i mean i expect
that you know we'll i'm actually be
seeing um krypt next week and i expect
conversations will will start to happen
about you know what he's got in store
and i i like to give them the uh
the respect of of being able to
do their writing process and and not be
harassed by actors going what are we
doing um but i can't wait you know they
always come up with uh
insane stuff so
yeah it's gonna be fun